[Music]
each week I ask on social media what
people would like to see us to bear on
this shirt and every week multiple
people ask me to debate what they
describe as mainstream media bias the
reason for this rightly or wrongly is
that they're perceived there to be a
strong anti brexit bias across broadcast
media when they look at political panels
they see Brick City as heavily
outnumbered by Ramona's and they've had
enough in response we've seen the brexit
party launched their own YouTube channel
and even their own newspaper whilst I
understand this I do fear we are at the
start of a slippery slope because it
will lead to a deepening of echo
chambers our media and needs to stop
seeing brexit supporters as an
afterthought and heavily outnumbering
them on debate shows I speak from
experience by the way when I say that
I've been on multiple shows as the only
brexit iere many times we need people to
trust our media and for that media to
accurately represent all views it's no
secret that Trust is fading and it
worries me where that will end just I
don't know where to start
I mean we start there just on papers to
begin with the Telegraph did it the mail
men on Sunday the Express The Sunday
Times is everything and their owners
Rupert Murdoch the Berkeley brothers
huge break for tears as you call them
next up the broadcaster's have to make
every effort to get people who plead the
brexit case on their shows as much as
possible now with respect it is hard to
find people who can actually argue for
brexit because it is such an idiotic
proposition because all they actually
say is it's the way of the will of the
people we won you lost get over it that
we had this vote three years ago you
simply say the same things
whenever again without actually drilling
into the economic chaos of what there is
and just let me finish and it is very
easy to find people who actually know
something about that you who know about
international trade like Pascal Lamy
like John Major like Tony Blair you know
you there are reams of people come on
and say intelligently about the issues
whereas everyone else just has circuits
it's like at the brexit party that was a
literally a party with one word slogan
they didn't have any policies this is
why it's hard to find people to come on
and talk about brexit go on then I'm
infuriated by you too but I'm gonna let
Nick comment I don't really know what
because you use words like it is so rude
maybe we're stronger all right I like
hear what you say about newspapers and
we could have a long and probably take
the rest of the show I sense there is
normally a bias within the BBC towards
remain I really I need no you just shout
it down when you don't hear what you
want to hear please let me just get out
the point and in a way the reaction of
both you and credit to Greg he's just
biding his time and I have to say you
who I really really do love you but your
reaction I actually don't need to say
anything I just urge that viewers to
recall how you're both reacted to the
point that I actually agree on that I
tend to agree with me I thought I don't
think there's much that I think what
happens is when you've got a major issue
polarized sighs both sides think the
media is against them
always yeah it happens the whole time
both sides thinks of me doing is now you
start off by saying we people are
trusting journalist less well that's not
true there's a nips Osmani poll that
shows that it's gone from 10 percent in
1993 but I think that's an aberration
but ninety fifteen percent trusted them
in the in the 90s it's up to 27 percent
now there was actually great at only a
quarter of people well it depends what I
think it's too
the question to us say - I trust you mr.
Wireless division because what you need
to do is which journalists which
organization would you but there is when
I was at the BBC when I was running the
BBC we did a lot of work on trying to be
impartial and what you discover is that
people who feel passionate about
something it's almost impossible to
satisfy them that you are the impartial
on both sides and that's what I remember
at the time of the Omak were getting a
lot of flack sand from Alastair Campbell
and Tony Blair for the BBC saying you
are not putting enough people on who
support our position well I'll tell you
what we went with a massive attempts to
try and I just want to know where is
your data for this I mean it's just is
this just your experience when you go on
because I know I've been on many shows
where I'm one of the few remains and
even on this debate show often there
will be you Carol and a Nick and then
there'll be just two of us it just
happens today we're are more remain as
than breaks the tears but that's not
always the case the Democrats the
world's Democrats and we love our great
country absurd
so I don't know I don't know where
you're getting this data from it doesn't
seem like it's empirical dates I mean it
looks like it's just your experience and
then the other bit what I would say is
having lived in America where actually
broadcast media is very partisan and
very opinionated I think in comparison
to the US I would say that our
television media is quite impartial
actually the network's go out of their
way to represent both views well we
believe your obligation all causes in
this country our obligation to provide
it and people talk about the mainstream
media stations like Sky News LBC C I'm
just going to leave this is the code
that they have to observe for all their
reporting and their discussion shows and
it goes on and on and on but I would
Arjuna would I would and it's difficult
for me shelter necessary quite well
there was this show on the 17th of April
there was this show on the 20
you're a fair-minded woman you must
detect sometimes a tone sometimes a tone
that the any brexit supportive
commentators are painted have been
almost Neandertal in their views you
must I mean I what I would say is and I
have to find a sort of diplomatic way of
saying this is that okay let's just look
at the demonstrations let's just take
the demonstrations as an example if you
look at the demonstrations from the
remains online I believe we have to
listen to the bracelet tears I'm not one
of these remain as is completely against
break the tears not at all but if you
look at the way the remainders
demonstrate or if you look at the way
remain has put their argument across
often not with you too but often if you
look at the voices of breaks it they are
very combative they are very belligerent
and I do think that there is a
difference in the thin the tube well I
am very pleased and I've chosen to
debate this topic because I do believe
that literally the reactions of you to I
do believe that that has summed up a lot
of the reactions across the media and
you talked about our there on one show
you talk yes but you talked about a
moment ago that basically you think that
you can't get any bricks the tears come
on programs that have got any sense
about them one of the challenges is a
lot of people are even afraid to admit
that their vertebreak sit yes and the
roof oh you got much more votes I know
many people that are professional
business people that would never sit on
a professional platform and say that
they voted bricks it and the reason
being is exactly the attitude that you
to of just displaying on a lease no
laughing it's true I think it's
outrageous what I said was in some it's
hard to find people who come on it and
make a strong economic case for brexit
in the face of all the evidence that
shows we are going to go off a cliff if
we have a no deal or even know what you
said well it was basically what I said
it's very hard because it's what it's an
emotional argument race as a factor
argument but find the people who are
coming on to say we want our country
back which is transient kind of okay
it's time to move on coming up while
this may soon be a thing of the
[Music]
[Music]